I heard a story about you in a tattoo
the one I think you're referring to I
don't have anyone had it removed from my
body by laser what part of your body was
there and young gentleman and we started
a toilet Affair and after two weeks of
knowing each other we had our names
tattooed on each other's bodies
uh we were we broke up four months later
and uh and so I had his I had it removed
by laser a few months later I was in a
lady in the film and I went to Cedar
Sinai and it was a great laser place but
what is today's is a little later after
that I met up with Raven again and he
said and he's
not judgments I have needs
um and he said he said he said you know
do you still have your tattoo honey I
was like No And I said do you still have
yours he went kinda and he pulled down
his pants and right there where I had
mine and instead of you see Alan and now
it says balance